what's going on Sky guys it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
Ahsoka has got me so hyped for the
future of Star Wars man because the
second coming of thrawn is upon us all
the hidden details sprinkled throughout
the first two episodes point to some
really exciting Star Wars Concepts that
involve shattering the very fabric of
space-time as we know it so let's get
into all of that fun Star Wars stuff
right now alright so the first two
episodes established the reason for this
Ahsoka season Morgan ellsbeth and her
two dark side buddies balen and shin are
trying to find a way to reach Grand
Admiral thrawn in a galaxy far far away
this of course after the Jedi Ezra
Bridger used the help of special
hyperspace traveling space whales called
pergil to warp thrawn's Azure
off to Regions unknown during his last
appearance in the Star Wars Rebels
series but one of the most intriguing
parts of the episode happens when Morgan
ellsbeth mentions how she's been
communicating with Ron despite not
having seen him since he vanished take a
listen
space
[Music]
when you speak of Dreams
fractured hopes
using her dark force abilities that she
learned during her training in life as a
night sister on the planet daphomir it
appears that Morgan has been able to
listen to the will of thrawn from
anywhere in the universe and though
having the ability to communicate with
your homie over long distances is pretty
sweet what is happening here in this
moment is technically a lot cooler than
you might think because the most
important words from this Morgan quote
are the words time and space in
particular time meaning that this
night's sister has been using her
witchcraft to listen to thrawn's
messages through time itself which is
crazy T-Mobile doesn't let me do that
T-Mobile Tuesdays
like there is only one place in Star
Wars Canon that has the ability to do
this and it is directly linked to both
the planet lothal as well as one of the
last places as we're went to before
Vanishing in the last season of rebels
it's a little place in the cosmos called
the world Between Worlds that's right my
nerd babies I believe the world Between
Worlds will strongly factor into the
plot of an Ahsoka series that is already
strongly centered and themed around
traveling unbelievably long distances
between worlds because that is precisely
what the world Between Worlds allows
people to do effectively giving mortal
beings a shortcut through space as well
as time a sacred place that even Emperor
Palpatine coveted and tried to conquer
for himself and the reasons I think the
world Between Worlds will Factor heavily
into the future of the sissoka series
have to do with one The Whispers that
Morgan hears in episode 2 to the Holy
Trinity symbolism found in the star map
tomb that point towards the mortise God
Guardians of the world between worlds
three the very design of the Ahsoka logo
itself which is the coolest part in my
opinion and for the golden lines that we
see emanate from the star map when
Morgan activates it as well as in the
heavily symbolic credits animations but
let's start with those Whispers And by
defining just what the world Between
Worlds even is for those of you who
haven't seen Star Wars Rebels yet the
world between worlds are a series of
Pathways generated by The Cosmic force
that exist outside of both space and
time in the Star Wars Universe
essentially like a pocket reality and
because this place isn't confined to the
linear nature of time Whispers of voices
from the prequel Sequel and original
trilogies of Star Wars can be heard as
Ezra Bridger walks down the white lines
that make up these Pathways if you were
to follow a familiar echoing voice down
one of these Pathways you could
eventually find yourself a portal to a
specific moment in time in the timeline
of that person's life when Ezra Bridger
was in the world Between Worlds he heard
voices that guided him to both his
former Master Kanan jarus as well as his
good friend friend Ahsoka Tano during
the moments of their lives where they
were about to be killed by agents of the
Empire however it is only Ahsoka Tano
that Ezra Bridger ends up pulling out of
her timeline to save her from dying by
Darth Vader's hand as Ahsoka would then
convince Ezra to abandon his temptation
to alter the course of time by Saving
Kanan Jairus life as doing so would
ultimately result in the deaths of all
the people Kanan died to save including
Ezra himself and though not yet having
traveled through the world Between
Worlds herself it seems that Morgan
ellsbeth has a dark side connection to
the cosmic force that allows her to hear
the voice of Braun instructing her
through time and space the only way
thrawn could whisper instructions to
Morgan elsbeth through time without
Force Powers as if Brawn were to somehow
gain access to the world Between Worlds
in the near future after Morgan Balin
and shim help him get there before the
end of the series time travel is really
weird man but anyway speaking of the
world between worlds let's take a quick
minute and notice the design of the
pathways as well as the circular and
triangular doorways scattered throughout
because I believe that lucasfilm has
purposely and cleverly designed the very
logo for the Ahsoka show around the
design of the world Between Worlds
itself alright look at this Ahsoka logo
real quick imagine the two letter A's as
triangle doorways and the center letter
O as a circular doorway then point your
attention to the line that cuts through
all the letters of Ahsoka like a pathway
running past all three of these doors
and making the center line for both the
A's as well as the H in Ahsoka and not
only this but behind the white Ahsoka
letters themselves you can see a blue
star map of the cosmos that the letters
stretch across a map that looks
extremely reminiscent of the map of the
cosmos found on the ceiling of the
lothal temple when Ezra visits for the
first time in episode 10 of rebels
season 1. by having a map of the cosmos
behind white Ahsoka logo letters themed
after the pathways of the world between
world lucasfilm is showing us how the
world Between Worlds allows people to
walk from one end of the cosmos to the
other super clever symbolism quite
honestly however because of how
dangerous these Pathways between points
in time can be the world Between Worlds
has been a safely guarded secret for
countless years in no small part to the
efforts of a super ancient and Ultra
powerful race of three Force users known
as the mortis Gods the mortise gods are
an incredibly important people in the
Star Wars universe as well as the life
of Ahsoka Tano specifically when they
were first introduced in the Clone Wars
animated series Ahsoka Anakin and
Obi-Wan learned that these three
powerful beings known as the daughter
the father and the son are directly
responsible for preserving the balance
between the light and dark sides of the
force throughout the cosmos with the
data representing the light side of the
force the sun representing the dark side
of the force and the father representing
and mediating the balance between the
two opposites these three entities
essentially form a Holy Trinity of the
force through the import important
Cosmic roles that they play in The
Cosmic dance between life and death in
fact Ahsoka Tano would have permanently
died after she was struck down by the
sun if it wasn't for the final selfless
Act of the daughter who sent the
remainder of her life force directly
into ahsoka's lifeless body re-sparking
The Light Within and bringing Ahsoka
back from the grave this forced concept
is called a forced life transfer and it
was Central to the plot of Star Wars
Episode 9 the rise of Skywalker as
forced life transfers are used multiple
times in that film like when Rey used
her life force to save that slither a
snake and then later to save kylo and
when Palpatine tried to suck the life
force out of Rey and Ben into himself
and finally when Ben transferred all of
his life force to bring Rey back from
the dead at the very end but anyways in
the final season of Star Wars Rebels
when Sabine and Ezra find one of the
entrances to the world Between Worlds in
an ancient forced temple on the planet
Lo fall they also find Palpatine's Army
there trying to unlock the secrets of
opening the more towards God's door as
Ezra and Sabine examine the mortise
guards mural that guards the door to the
world Between Worlds Sabine notices that
the secret of unlocking the door lies
within the positioning of the mortise
God's hands the hands of these mortise
gods are extremely important as they
directly connect to these statues and
carvings that Ahsoka comes across at the
beginning of episode 1. mostly because
these hand positions seem to represent
the overall Natures of these three
character archetypes the daughters
lowered but open hand represents the
light side's Affinity towards
selflessness generosity and peace the
sun's raised in closed fists represents
the dark side selfish and violent nature
while the father's raised but open hand
represents an authoritative balance
between both the light and dark sides of
the forts Ezra then places his opened
hand on the Open Hand of the selfless
and generous daughter which then causes
the daughter to generously convince her
father to open the door to the world
Between Worlds and then later when Ezra
needs to close the door to this insanely
powerful realm he plays closed fist on
the closed Fist of the selfish son who
then uses his selfish nature to close
the door and prevent anyone from getting
inside but anyways the reason why I even
bring the mortise Gods up is because
this crazy ancient mortis God Trinity
seems to be super important and Dave
filoni's evolving Star Wars narrative
because these mortise God archetypes
seem to have inspired ancient
civilizations that existed long before
the events of the Ahsoka show mysterious
civilizations like the kind Ahsoka comes
across in episode 1 as well as the
ancient zepho civilization that the Jedi
calcasus discovers in the recent and
super popular Star Wars Jedi Fallen
order video game from respawn
entertainment fantastic game I freaking
love it but let's start off with the
civilization from this tomb planet from
the start of episode 1 of Ahsoka let's
check this out when Ahsoka first arrives
at the tomb we can see her approach
three large statues built by this
ancient civilization of force users but
it's only when Ahsoka drops into the
tomb itself and examines the carvings of
the wall that we can see that these
three are meant to reflect the light
dark and balanced motifs of the mortise
Gods especially if we did what Sabine
did in Rebels and examined the hands the
first carving that Ahsoka looks at has
Open Hands lowered and to the left much
like the daughter's hands are in the
lothaw mural then the next carving shows
a figure selfishly enclosing a star map
in both hands hearkening the sun's
closed Fist and selfish nature and a
third figure with one hand below the
star map and another hand raised and
opened like the father's hand is in the
mural with the center structure holding
the star map itself being in the center
of a triquetra symbol on the ground a
symbol famously associated with
trinities in various cultures and
religions in Christianity the triquetra
is the symbol for the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit Trinity in Star Wars the
triikeetra appears to represent the
father of the Son and the daughter as
well as the concepts of balance Darkness
and Light that these three archetypes
represent and like I alluded to before
we can see the father son and daughter
archetypes in respawn Star Wars video
games as well specifically within the
mysterious culture of the ancient zepho
people and Jedi Fallen order halcastis
explores the tombs of a revered Trinity
of zepho sages looking for circular Keys
called astriums that function a lot like
the circular star map Ahsoka finds in
that tomb while searching for these
astriums Cal comes across zephalo murals
that were intentionally designed to
mirror the mortis God's Trinity just
like that ancient civilization did with
those figures in the Ahsoka episode 1 2
the zephos Trinity manifested as three
sages that represented each of these
three mortis God archetypes the peaceful
nature loving zephosage elrim that loved
Chewbacca's greened Homeworld of kashyyk
and represented the light side of the
force the ruthless zephosage kujet who
dabbled with the dark side of the force
and loved Morgan ellsmith's Homeworld of
dathomir so much that he had himself
buried inside of his Palace there and
the prideful zephosage mitral who
represented a middle balance between the
Darkness and Light much like the
prideful father did but most importantly
we can see this zepho Trinity pictured
together in a mural within the zepho
Vault on the planet bogano in a very
similar way to how we see these three
figures in the Tomb in Ahsoka episode 1
with the zephosage elrim on the left
with a lowered and open left hand like
the daughter the zephosage kujet on the
right with hands hovering over each
other pocketing to the selfish nature of
the sun and the balanced but prideful
Sage mitral in the Middle with their
hands neutrally together representing
the prideful and balanced nature of the
father however the most interesting of
all three of these zephosages in terms
of the Ahsoka narrative has got to be
kujet and his Palace turned tomb on the
planet dathomir where he is buried with
his hands in the same greedy and
enclosed hand positioning that Ahsoka
sees in the Tomb and there is a reason
for this kujet's Palace is one of the
darkest places that calc Estus visits in
that game not only because it's located
on the dark side planet of dathomir but
also because it tells dark story of how
cujit slaughtered a bunch of his
zathonian followers who tried to take
his ruthless power away from him but
after the sage cujet's Dark Side reign
of terror the zepho race realized that
they had completely lost themselves to
the dark side of the force and because
of this decided to leave the known
Galaxy altogether to find a new
beginning far away in a distant unknown
region of space this all being said
knowing that the ancient zephal race has
links to the mortise God culture and
builds circular star map like astriums
that their leader kujet was buried with
on the planet dathomir the Knight sister
Morgan ellsbeth having knowledge of how
circular keys from ancient civilizations
can lead to distant temples Far Far Away
makes perfect sense
and ancient people from a distant Galaxy
and if the star map is linked to the
mortise Gods it would also serve to
explain what Balin meant when he told
shim that he was ultimately seeking
power from his relationship with Ron and
Morgan
such as you've never dreamed
perhaps access to the temple will
provide some clarity my Lord
we must
most The Power Within I believe much
like the emperor did Balin is coveting
the power of the world Between Worlds
the power to Traverse time and space and
alter the threads of Fate forever a
power that promises the rekindling of
war and New Beginnings for those who
have died and that star map is the key
to all of that but speaking of star maps
and the world Between Worlds Sabine
already knows the correlation between
the two as she observed that the mortise
God mural on the fall was actually a
giant star map with golden line much
like how the star map is represented in
the Ahsoka show especially when we get
imagery of the star map during the
Ahsoka credit sequence I think this is
it
what the painting on the temple is like
a star map but none that I'm familiar
with those lines are like paths and the
Rings are planets the animation in the
Ahsoka credits is just a giant golden
star map to the far off planet that
thrawn and Ezra were warped off to by
these space traveling Pergo creatures
tentacled creatures represented as
constellations in all the star Maps much
like we can see the loathe wolves are in
that animation as well as in the stars
in the world Between Worlds this is
significant because both loath Wolves
and the Pergo are able to naturally
access hyperspeed on the realm which is
kind of crazy so the reason why they
have constellations represented in Star
Wars is likely associated with their
connection to hyperspace grogu even
briefly notices some purple space Wheels
while traveling hyperspace in the
Mandalorian right now in the Ahsoka show
Morgan ellsbeth is building this eye of
Scion installation to be able to warp to
thrawn's location because that is
far far away but once thrawn's artistic
eye is able to unlock the secret of the
world Between Worlds Morgan's artificial
eye of Scion will no longer be required
because he could just walk to anywhere
he wants to go the mortise Gods held the
secrets to instantaneous space travel
between planets and those secrets are
hidden within the Arts and ruins of
various cultures the only person in Star
Wars with an eye for art equal to
sabines to unlock all the secrets left
behind by the mortise gods and the
civilizations inspired by the mortise
Gods is none other than Grand Admiral
thrawn himself The Heir or Scion to the
Empire if Grand Admiral thrawn can
figure out just how to walk the cosmic
threads of Fate thrawn could ignite a
war unlike anything anyone has ever seen
a war that spans throughout all of time
and space and to stop him Ahsoka will
likely eventually find herself back in
the world Between Worlds once again but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
masterton on Twitter if you guys want to
see me tweet some weird but most
importantly you can follow heavy
spoilers here on YouTube and anywhere we
are on the social medias do that right
now or I will personally go through the
world Between Worlds and find you at
your 12 year old birthday party and just
throw your cake on the ground just
kidding I won't do that but subscribe to
heavy spoilers anyway
but anyways thanks again for watching I
love you guys so much I'll see you guys
next time goodbye